As the crowd is screaming, "Run, you
effing coward." The police are escorting
them to the Israeli consulate as they're
throwing cones at the police and they're
depicting Jews eating dead babies. This
is in Denmark. What you're seeing here
is Muslim riots across This is Denmark.
This is across Europe, London, Paris,
New York, and I think I have Florida on
here, too. And this is just in the past
the past
year with the Nazi salute. And we're the
Nazis, remember?
France, thousands of cars, thousands of
cars are burned um intermittently. Uh
10,000 cars in one night.
Made the news very little. Yeah. But
it's it's a it's a it's constant.
What are they watching?
They're angry.
They're angry. I mean, if it's not uh if
it's not Iraq, I mean, in the case of in
Paris, uh there was a um a Muslim young
man who was running from um a crime and
he ran into an electrical fence and he
got killed.
This is a crowd demanding that an
Israeli flag be removed from someone's
apartment, from someone's window, and
the police went up and they removed the
flag. This is in Germany.
And while Israel is something of a
tangential issue, it's a critical issue
because Israel is on the front lines of
the jihad.
Period.
They want Israel because believe me,
it's not this tiny little oilless,
goldless, six, nine miles at its wide
piece of land that they want. They want
Israel because it is in the Quran that
the Jews must be annihilated and the
Jews must be um you know any Jew you see
hiding behind a tree you must kill them.
I mean Islamic anti-semitism is very
much a part of Quranic doctrine and
that's why you see such virulent
anti-semitism on the Arab media and the
Muslim media and in the streets.
Sweden is is it's scary what's happening
in Sweet Sweden. This was because a
tennis player, an Israeli tennis player
had won a match and was coming to Sweden
to
play. They burned the buses, the police
buses. They burned the cars. It was
just, it was
madness. Europe is on fire. And if any
of you have been to Europe recently,
it's not the Europe of your parents that
was so near and dear post World War II.
It's completely and utterly changed. And
uh I don't think that Europe understood
the lessons it should have learned from
World War II. They came away with this
idea that nationalism was bad and that
uh a good idea would be to eliminate
nationalism and come up with this kind
of EU gobblety goop that basically is so
politically correct. Okay, you can shut
it
down. When what Europe should have done
and taken away from World War II is that
they were monsters and that they were
evil and they have to defeat evil and
they have to be good. It's just that
simple. The battle is just that simple.
Um, okay, let's start from the
beginning. First of all, I'm Pamela
Geller and contrary to popular belief,
I'm a human rights activist.
[Applause]
uh care, the unindicted co-conspirator
uh Muslim Brotherhood
linked Hamas Tide
uh civil rights group. Thank you very
much. characterizes the defense of free
speech, uh, freedom of conscience, um,
the equality of rights for women, uh, as
hate speech because it's denied under
Islamic law. And what they do is they
try to shut up everybody who speaks
against Islamic
supremacism. And they're very successful
at it. And I want to just thank you from
the bottom of my heart for having the
guts, the guts to have me speak. I mean,
KR got Franklin Graham. No, no,
[Applause]
you care got Franklin Graham banned from
the Pentagon. A righteous, pious man
like that. It's shocking. It's shocking
that it's not front page news. They got
Robert Spencer, a leading scholar on
Islam, banned from the Library
Association. Isn't the Library
Association the gatekeeper to human
thought?
How dare they? How dare they attack one
human thought? And what they're trying
to do is make people like me toxic and
marginal so we can't speak while they
literally impose Islamic law, Sharia law
here in America. Now, if that sounds to
you as something really
outrageous, let me
explain. The fact that what I'm saying
could even be determined or accused of
being hate speech is a form of Sharia
law. In Islam, slander is not what we
think of as slander, where you actually
maliciously lie or accuse to hurt
another person. Slander is anything that
insults a Muslim about Islam. So, we are
self-imposing Sharia when the cartoons
uh the Danish cartoons broke. And if you
didn't see them, it's because the media
would not uh would not run them or
broadcast them. I wish you would go
online and um Google Danish cartoons and
look at them. They were very innocuous.
But we self-imposed some kind of a
censorship. It's not even state-run
censorship. It's a self-imposed Sharia
law. It's freedom of speech. It's all
about freedom of speech. And I am
telling you and I am warning you that
freedom of speech is the line in the
sand. That's right.
The principle of freedom of speech is
not concerned with the content of a
man's
speech. Nor does it uh protect only the
expression of good ideas, but all ideas.
Because if not that, otherwise who
decides? Who decides what's a good idea?
Obama. Who decides? The Council of
American Islamic Relations. All ideas.
You see, you're sitting here and you
think you're in a little room in
Gatlinburgg. Did I say that right?
Thank you.
You are This is a battlefield. That's
right. And And this is a a victorious
battle site.
Because I am telling you that the war is
in the information battle space. The war
is in the battle of ideas. The guns, the
bombs, the bloodshed that comes as a
result of what goes on
here. And this attack on freedom of
speech. You see, I don't care what they
say. They say the most egregious,
lielist, slanderous things about me. I
don't care as long as I have the
opportunity to speak. I know that my
ideas are superior. I I know that
Western civilization is superior to to
to Islamic society. I know
this. So, I know I'll win because my
ideas are better. But once you remove a
free man's
right, unalienable right endowed by God
to speak freely, he has no other choice
but to get violent. You will have no
other alternative. This is the line in
the sand, freedom of speech. You know,
when I was very young, there was a big
news story and I really was not paying
attention to the news, but it was really
one of those that stories that kind of
seizes uh captures you. There was talk
that there was going to be a big Nazi
march in Skoi uh Jewish uh highly Jewish
suburb in in in outside of Chicago. And
everybody was shocked. You know, the
Nazis are marching. We can't have Nazis
marching. Oh my god, this that. Well, at
the end of the day, the Nazis marched in
Skoi, as reprehensible as it was, as
goostepping and disgusting as it was,
because the right to free speech is more
important than anything else.
I cannot I cannot stress this enough
because free speech is under attack.
It's under attack on the web. It's under
attack uh by the administration. You
heard Obama just last week saying, you
know, some information ain't so good and
some of, you know, that folksy kind of
a, you know, manufactured, uh, I'm one
of the people way. Um, and we we some we
go to the Huffington Post. I mean, the
sites he's recommending, I live on the I
live online and I'm telling you that is
a hate site, an anti-Semitic speech, a
leftist. I mean it's so out there that
that kind of that kind of invective
would have been on the margins the very
margins of society 25 years ago.
Something has happened. The left is has
has completely overtaken the dialogue.
The left has completely seized the day
and because there is a leftist Islamic
alliance there is no way that the ideas
of Islam could have penetrated the
society as it did without the help of
the left.
Uh it's it would have been impossible.
For example, okay, let's see. How are we
how are they imposing Islam on a secular
society? That's a good question. They're
mosquing the workplace. And what that is
is where they you they they import these
whole Muslim communities from Somalia to
work in meat packing plants and gley and
so on and so forth. And that's why
immigration is such a critical issue,
right? Because they're not letting in
doctors from England. I know because I
have friends in England that are dying
to get here. they can't get in, but they
are importing these whole Muslim
communities. What happens is they they
all like Nashville, that's a big gateway
city. They settle them in little small
towns and frankly the people don't know
what hit them that live there because
Americans are good. They're good people
and they are it's sort of the hatred of
the good for being the good. It's sort
of gotten turned around on us and they
impose Muslim prayer times in the
workplace. They go to the union. The
union says, "Well, we want to be, you
know, tolerant." What happened was what
they didn't count on was the non-Muslim
workers. The non-Muslim workers didn't
want to lengthen their day. They had to
lengthen their day. And the Muslim
workers, non-Muslim workers were
generally Hispanic and Jesusloving
people. And I want you to know, there
was a lot of there was rioting. There
was violence. Did you hear about this
fighting between
No. How do they How do they How are they
imposing Sharia? How are they imposing
Islamic law? Uh, in New Jersey, a little
Muslim boy wants to pray in school. He's
a cute little boy. He looks up at the
camera and the New York Times is only
too happy to take that picture. And what
they do is they make a prayer room. And
now in the public school, Muslim boy is
praying. What's the big deal? The big
deal is it sets a dangerous precedent.
The big deal is we must separate mosque
from state. The big deal is there is no
separation of mosque and state. Mosque
is
state. I live in New York
City. They are building a 911 mega I'm
sorry. Um hey,
they're building a 911 mega mosque, a
15story mega mask. And if you saw the
artist
rendering, it's a cruel joke that it
looks like a
tower. It's a cruer joke that they're
opening it on September the 11th.
Now, let me tell you
something. In coming to this fight, I
ask you to first learn everything. Don't
listen to anything that you read or or
hear because everything that's coming to
you visav the government or the media
has literally been vetted by the Muslim
Brotherhood. They have literally um
infiltrated senior level of the Pentagon
uh of the executive branch. I mean you
have a brand new department at the um
state department to Muslim outreach.
Okay. uh reports directly to Hillary
Clinton. Um uh the uh care is a Muslim
Brotherhood proxy. MAS, Muslim American
Society is a Muslim proxy. This is all
by the way, this was all substantiated
in the Holyland trial where K was an
unindicted
co-conspirator. Every
singl circle of North America finances
80% of the mosques in America.
isna. Everything you hear and read and
see comes from these
organizations. I'm telling you, you have
to do your own research whether you like
it or not because America is being
tested in a way she's never been tested
before. This the time is now. The time
is now to fight back. You're going to
have to fight back. I can tell you a
couple things. I can tell you just as we
revere our grandparents for fighting the
great fight and defeating Nazism, our
grandchildren are going to hate us.
They're going to hate us because they're
going to be held hostage by nuclear
terrorist regimes by this imposition of
it's a death by a thousand cuts. This
imposition of Sharia law. You see how
the media You see how the media just ran
everything Cass said about me.
Everything a lie. What happened to
journalism? The AP reporter contacted
me. I gave him three succinct
statements. Not a word, not one word
from me. But they did drop, you know,
anti anti-Islam speaker. That's big
because everybody knows that I'm an
anti-Muslim, Islamophobic, racist bigot.
[Applause]
There is an where. There. That's right.
It's all about, listen to me, it's all
about individual rights. It's all about
individual rights. There are no
individual rights in Islam. It's this
country was founded by great men who
risked everything. Everything, their
family, their wealth for an idea for the
most brilliant and magnificent idea in
human
history. A government based on
individual rights. Period.
And that Declaration of Independence is
the most spectacular almost religious
document, the most brilliant document
ever written in human
[Applause]
history. It's not that that document is
failing. It's that we are failing that
document.
There is nothing wrong with it. It is
perfect.
And America was as successful as she was
at that book, The 5,000-year leap. Why
there was such a 5,000 year leap in
humanity. Because for the first time in
history, there was a governmentbased the
most noble experiment in human history
was America. And we're tossing it out
with both hands. Did you hear Patrick
Henry say, "Give me liberty or give me
death unless I insult you."
Yeah. You can be insulted. You can
insult me. That's the way it goes,
right?
Um there is let let me try and also get
my there's a lot
um but oh uh all
day the the everybody can understand the
violent jihad. It's obvious we see it we
see it we see it in Fort Hood where
Major
Hassan came out as a grand jihadi on his
grand rounds.
his PowerPoint presentation, I would
have showed it if we had better uh I
don't want to get bogged down with
technical stuff, but his PowerPoint
presentation that he made on grand
rounds is I use because it is the most
succinct boil down to its essential oils
PowerPoint presentation on jihad. And
the Pentagon in its review,
investigation, and recommendations never
mentions Islam, never mentions jihad,
never mentions religious motivation. How
are you going to fight a war if you are
afraid to speak its name?
[Applause]
So, there's a self-imposed Sharia. We
won't speak ill of Islam. Oh yes, we
will. And in and in and listen and
always and know something and getting
back to the mosque and I know I'm sort
of all over the place so I I apologize
but it's a lot I'd like to get in there
in Islamic history symbolism is very
important. Every time they conquer a
land they always take the church or the
temple the synagogue and they build
right over it. Look what they did the
Hajias Sophia uh the most beautiful
church outside of the Vatican uh or the
Jewish holiest site in the world which
was the temple mount which is alkuds and
the Jews can't go there now. Okay. Um
and this is what this mosque is at 911.
It is the ultimate flag of conquest. I
mean could you imagine the Muslim call
to prayer on actually on 911? Oh my god.
The symbolism cannot be understated. I
assure you that this building will
become the icon on every Islamic
website, on every call to jihad, on
every jihadist website. This will be the
icon for the war on the west. And there
is a war on the west. Whether you like
it or not, it is
al-hisra. And you know, Islamic history
starts at Alhijra, meaning the
immigration. The immigration, they
immigrate, they colonize, and then all
of a sudden, you know, you turn around,
you go, how did I get here? There's an
academic jihad. You see what's happening
on college campuses? They're rewriting
history. They're rewriting reality. When
a girl like me is called a racist um
Islamophobic anti-Muslim bigot and I
can't speak places because I'm merely
telling the
truth. We are living in a dangerous age.
Telling the truth. Truth is the new hate
speech.
And just telling the truth makes you a
hero. We live in so cheap and tordrian
age that just telling the truth makes
you a hero. And yet there are so few
heroes. I have hope
because I'm looking at a movement that's
not afraid.
It's
huge. It's huge. It's a very big deal.
And you saw what they did immediately as
soon as you started to rise up. You were
racist. Yeah. You were a big Now I on my
blog Atlas Shruggs I every time they
said racist and they were I saw when it
started. It started last summer on the
Huffington Post and I took the pictures
that they cropped. They cropped the
pictures. They had a guy sweet blonde
kid. He's gone like this. They cut out
the sign so he looks like he's Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. You have no idea what you're up
against. This is what they do. And so
now maybe America, because Americans
themselves were called racist bigots,
maybe now when they're listening to the
media propaganda, the state the
self-inforced state propaganda because
nobody's doing it. They're imposing it
themselves. Um maybe now you won't be so
quick to say, "Oh yeah, that's a bad
guy." Because you are the bad guy now.
How does it feel? Feels good. Hey,
I'm loving this crowd.
There's an academic jihad where they're
rewriting history. They're rewriting
your children's history books. Any of
you with children in in grade school, go
look at the book. Go look at the book
and see the three chapters on Islam.
Once the prophet Muhammad, they won't
let the books come home. You have they
won't let the books come home.
You have to get involved. Listen, we had
our time. We had our time with the Brady
Bunch. We had our time. We had our time,
you know, with Cheetos and Twinkies. We
had our time. We have to go to war. And
what troubles me is that this crowd is a
much older crowd. They have completely
co-opted the young. They're like bots.
They're like that movie Invasion.
[Applause]
Hey, it's a big deal. It's a big deal.
I've spoken to college kids and let me
tell you something. You want to meet a
rugged group of individualists beaten,
batted, and tougher than that, that's
them. Because to be a conservative on a
college campus,
is to be in a goolog, you know, and be a
political dissident.
There's an academic jihad. They, the
Saudis, uh, they have given enormous
amounts of money. It's all about money.
Enormous amounts of money to these
universities. 20 million Georgetown 20
million that we know about to Harvard.
Uh we're up against uh a serious
generation of miseducated and and and
and and dangerous thinking. Very
dangerous thinking. There's a litigation
jihad. There's a litigation jihad. And
what that is is it's called lawfare.
They sue you. They sue you. You say
something they don't like, they sue you.
Now you get a lawyer. Okay? By the way,
the Saudis gave K $50 million. That's
what they do with this money. They sue
people. We've all been sued. Now, there
are people that will come pro bono. But
let me tell you something. For an
individual to be sued, your home, your
family, it's a very scary thing. So,
nine times out of 10, people shut up.
Not me. No, not you. But, but believe
me, they're scary. They scare people.
There is a suppression of our basic
freedoms. We are under siege here. Under
siege. and they've never been more
empowered and more emboldened because
you do have an Islamophilia president.
You do
now. Um guess that
I have a book that I've co-written with
Robert Spencer coming out July 27th
called The PostAmerican Presidency, the
Obama administration's war on America.
Buy it. It will explain to you
everything is that's going on, why it's
going on. I've been researching him for
since January 2007. I broke so many
stories on Obama before the election.
The media wouldn't touch it. I broke the
contributions from a Hamas controlled
Rafa refugee camp in Gaza. By the way,
you're not allowed to accept one dime.
Not one dime, illegal dime. I documented
millions just by going through FEC
documents with the help of my readers.
Millions. He supported Odinga in Kenya.
Odinga against our ally uh uh Kikaku
Kikaku the president there, forgive my
spelling. Um uh he backed the
Islamist sympathizing Odinga campaign
for him, raised money for him. He Well,
you know what? It's cousin. It's very
That's what he said. He said it was his
cousin. It's very troubling because this
is in the White House. This is in the
White House. He's abandoned our allies.
He abandoned Honduras. What went on in
Honduras was a classic example of
democracy at work. Here you had a
Chavezbacked president, a Chavez back
coup where he tried to make himself sort
of president for life and the people
said, "Hey, yeah, yeah, yeah, no, two
terms. That's what we do. Two terms." He
said, "No, I'm I'm going for more. No
ter and it went to the Supreme Court. It
went through all the machinations of a
democracy and still he said, "I'm doing
it." So they threw him out. They didn't
kill him. They threw him out.
And then and then and then Obama backs
them.
Obama is giving gave the tacid approval
of the United States of
America last summer when the people of
Iran stood up, took to the streets and
with their bare flesh met bullets and
bricks and marched for democracy. And we
better keep doing the same here or we're
going to lose it. And we abandoned those
people. We've been waiting for that. Was
Bush not waiting for that for years? He
said he would say, "I want you to know
in Iran, I'm with you." He said he
wouldn't agitate and he wouldn't make it
happen. And I have some issues with
President Bush because I He should have
taken out those nukes. I'm sorry. That's
how I feel because again, those Listen,
Iran has proxies. Syria is a vassel for
Iran. Hezbollah, Hezbollah, Hezbollah, I
want you to remember Hezbollah. Forget
about Israel for a
second.
1981 attacked our boys, killed 241
Marines
in Lebanon.
That was Hezbollah. That was that was
Iran. And that was after 1979 when they
took our hostages. We should have
marched it that day. That day, President
Carter
[Applause]
destroyed destroyed our our currency,
destroyed our stock, destroyed our
reputation, and destroyed our very
spine, you know, gave Oh, which is so
disgusting. Okay, I'm back. Well, yeah.
Well, he is back, but actually he's a
Obama is worse.
Obama is work. Obama is a culmination of
the Islamic uh leftist alliance. Our
dictator well you know he's acting in a
dictator-like fashion. You see he wants
to now he tried to control the net.
That's the only place by the way the
internet bad and good where you're going
to get unfeded information. And I'm
going to tell you there are things that
are said about me on the net. I mean I'm
a drunken blogger. I'm a hook blogger.
I'm a drug add blogger. I I I'm a
mobster. I mean, such a I don't care.
I'm just telling you I don't care.
People say, "Why don't you sue and this
and that so I could give them uh more
stuff to write about? I got too much on
my plate. I got too much to do. I don't
even care about that." But there has to
be one place in the world where you can
get unfeted information. You're going to
have to be your own editor. You're going
to have to look at something and say,
"Oh, this guy's nuts." Or, "Where did he
get that? How can he say that? What's
his source?" I source everything.
Everything is sourced. And so I'm
telling you, we have an enormous job to
do. We have enormous work. Now, on June
6th, any of you have that are family in
the New York area, friends, vets, tea
parties, anybody, please come down. I am
organizing a rally with Robert Spencer.
Our organization is uh Sio, stop
Islamization of America. And we are
organizing a rally against the 9/11
mosque. And we're doing this because
they're going to build it. I'm telling
you, they're going to build this mosque.
And, you know, they're always talking
about sensibilities. You can't say the
word Muhammad on television uh because
you you're going to offend us. You can't
run the Danish cartoons because you're
going to offend us. You can't put
Muhammad in a huggy bear costume because
you can't show a depiction of Muhammad.
We have to be constantly constantly club
like baby seals.
Well, I'm offended by a 9/11 mega
mosque. I'm offended. My sensibilities
are offended. And I think that ground
zero should be a mosque-free zone
because it it is a shrine to the violent
ideology that inspired jihad. Now, the
thing is they talk to us. It's so
insulting. It's the ultimate act of
outreach. Yeah. Yeah. Outreach. It's the
ultimate act of dawa inviting. You know,
you have to you have to Islam. They have
to invite you before they conquer you.
They have to invite you to convert
before they conquer you. What would be
more appropriate is to take that
building and to make it a shrine to the
victims. Yeah. Over over a millennium of
jihadi wards, land appropriations,
enslavements, and and jihad and a
center, an academic center working to
expune the Quran of its violent texts.
That is the answer. That is the answer.
And by the way, when they tell you about
all these different versions of
Islam, in the words of the Turkish prime
minister, there is no moderate Islam.
There is no extreme Islam. Islam is
Islam.
And the Taliban said it too when Obama
was outreaching to his partners, his new
partners, the Taliban. Hello.
They said the same thing to him. So the
question is they say well it's how you
interpret it. Again you have to
understand something. The Old Testament
and the New Testament were written by
men. The Quran is allegedly the word of
Allah. Allah said it to Muhammad. He had
it seared in his memory like John Kerry
and he dictated it and it's the word of
God. Allah, excuse me.
Um, yes, I understand that. But my point
here is that at least in Judaism and
Christianity, you are encouraged to
think. You are encouraged to question.
You are encouraged. Period. In Islam,
you are not allowed to reform. It is an
absolute rule. Reinterpret. They have a
word for it. It's called hypocrisy. If
you attempt to do it, you're a hypocrite
and it's punishable by death.
Do you know that when they say the
Muslim calls to prayer five times a day,
you know when they get down and they say
that they are cursing Christians and
Jews in that prayer five times a day?
Did you know that? Yes.
You don't know a lot of things. That's
why I'm telling you, you have to learn
everything first and stop with that. I'm
a mean girl and I'm mean I'm mean to I'm
Muslims. I want to save Muslims. They've
been doing it for 1480 years and very
successful at it because Islam is the
only religion with a propaganda arm.
It's called
tea. In Islam, you're mandated to
perform tea. And tea is deception to
advance Islam. Lies to advance Islam.
When they come out and they say that
9/11 had nothing to do with Islam, that
is a lie. When they come out and they
say that this mosque is an outreach to
the ummah, that is a lie. When they
refer to those harmed on 911, those
harmed, the air was filled with
humanity. Literally
haunt the
smell in New York
City for
months was
indescribable harmed. How dare you? How
dare you not make recompense ever since
that
day? Instead, we can't do enough. We
can't give them enough. We can't give
enough aid to Muslim countries. Obama
has stopped the space shuttle program
and has redirected their efforts to
Muslim countries. Hello. What is that
about? Redirected the efforts of NASA to
help and aid Muslim countries. Why?
Greece and 46 million to Tennessee. Yes.
How about Tennessee and the floods? I
know. I don't hear about it in New York.
What is that about? But I'm still
hearing about Katrina. Obama doesn't
care about white people. Oh, listen.
Obama. And I want you to know a black
guy just said that.
Well, that's interesting. It's interest
It It's interesting because he really is
more Arab. He has more Arab blood than
Muslim. I mean, than than than white,
but then black. Excuse me. But that's
getting off the topic. I don't care what
a color a man's skin is. I care about
the content of his character. I care
about his ideas. I am I I
speak I speak for the the smallest
minority in the world. I speak for
individuals. I am an individual rights
activist. If I had a party, my party
would be either the capitalist party,
the most benevolent system in the world.
I'm so sick and tired of hardworking
people and and and success being
demonized and failure being
exalted. As soon as someone's a failure.
Oh, what a failure. A brilliant failure.
The biggest failure ever. And that or
versus a guy. Oh, he's a businessman.
Let's get him. The engine of the world,
the producers make things happen. And
that's why in a crisis, every idea of
the left always fail. Because in a
crisis, when something terrible happens,
who do you need? You need the producers.
Period. So, we we've gotten off on such
a such um a bad track. And and what
scares me is it's not it's it's not the
devotion of the followers that scare me.
It's the confusion on our side.
But we don't need
everybody. We only need a third of the
people. And November is critical.
And if you play golf or you go to
NASCAR, whatever your hobby is, you're
going to have to slide in another hobby
called uh saving America,
you're going to have to you're going to
have to get involved in the precincts.
You're going to have to get involved.
You look at your local politics in your
committees, in your towns, on your
school boards, because what they do is
nobody ever shows up. So, you know what
a Democrat does? He sits in a Republican
seat. And then all of a sudden, you say,
"How did I how did I get here?" You got
to do it. You got to do it. And I know
you may be tired and I know you may be
weary, but the enemy is not. And I have
learned so much from
them. And they told her parents and her
parents got a phone call and said, "Your
daughter converted to Christianity and
if you don't straighten her out or
else." So now they say she comes home
and the father with the laptop over her
head because she would meet people on,
you know, Facebook. I'm going to kill
you if you have this Jesus in your
heart. and they're going to go back to
Sri Lanka. We're for certain you would
never hear from her again. She runs
away. Okay. Now, couple things. I have
never seen a runaway pursued like this
girl was pursued. You got runaways
selling their bodies, selling drugs,
working for the man, working for the
pimp all over this country. You never
hear from them, right?
But the pastor that drove her to the
bus, the five minutes to the bus, when
she ran away, she want said she wanted
to get as far away from Ohio as possible
so they couldn't find her. The pastor is
going to be prosecuted for contributing
to the unruliness of a minor for driving
her to the bus. That is Sharia law. She
ran away. They brought her got her back.
I know I worked tirelessly uh to make
the med make the people aware of what
was happening because the media of
course you know she was brainwashed by
this crazy cult called
Christianity now she basically has been
living under house arrest which by the
way is Islamic law because female
apostates that's apostasy female
apostates must stay under house arrest
until they
recant and
Care was advising the parents. Care
appointed the lawyer. Care. The last
thing they want is for young girls to be
able to think for themselves to think
that they can leave lead their own
lives. Increasingly, we are seeing in
this country honor
killings in Canada. I document them all
the time. Just yesterday, three British
uh um Muslims were um visiting in
Pakistan. They were murdered in an honor
killing. Uh the day before that, a girl
in Germany was hacked to death. hacked
attack by by her father. Um, and they'll
say it's not Islamic. 96% of the honor
killings in the world are not Islamic.
But you know what? The 4% Yeah. Then you
have, you know, I'm sure you know about
clitorctomies. Yeah. In many Muslim
countries to remove the pleasure from
the female, they I mean in Egypt 96% of
the women, the girls have been
clitorised. So, I don't know if you're
aware of it, but two weeks ago, the
American Academy of Pediatrics had
advised that they perform a nick a nick
on a girl's clitoris. You know, wouldn't
do any real damage, but it would sort
of, you know, uh, replicate the act. And
why? So, they don't go back to their own
countries and get the thing hacked
off. What that is is sanctioning female
mutilation. It's sanctioning it. What
that is is saying it's okay. Not this
much, this much. And you think they're
going to be happy with a nick once they
got the nick. They're going to want the
slash. That's right. But this is
happening in America. This in America
would be abhorrent to our culture.
That's right. It is a rejection. This is
not multiculturalism. This is national
suicide.
And it is happening. These are stories
you don't see the media. Where did I get
that story by the way on the uh
clarctomies? the New York Times. You
should have seen how they wrote it up.
So full of tolerance and understanding.
No tolerance for me. No tolerance for my
free speech. No tolerance for tea
parties, but tolerance for the haters,
the fascists, and the totalitarian.
Because that is the left. The left align
itself
always with the totalitarian ideology of
the day. Whether it's Stalinism, whether
it's communism, whether it's fascism,
whether it's Islam,
because it's a way to control the
people. Yeah. So, I'm I'm going to
close. I'm just going to remind you that
June 6th, if you know anybody that cares
about this country that's on the eastern
seabboard, you can email me at write
ritlas. Write
writ.com. Uh there are people coming up
I95. There are people coming from
Oregon. There are people in their pickup
trucks. Uh they'll pick you
up. You will be you will be
vetted. There will be no car bombers
allowed. Um uh also I'd like you to pick
up my book. You have to get your news
from the net. If you want to know what's
going on in this world, you need to get
your news on the net. And by the way,
you have to you have to support Israel.
And I'm going to tell you why you have
to.
You have to support Israel for a number
of reasons. First, because in any war
between the civilized man and the
savage, you always side with the
civilized man.
The IDF is the most benevolent army in
the world. I am telling you, I have been
there. If you read the the not the
Goldstone report and they love to find
the Jewish guy that's gonna stab his
people in the head and put them up front
and we got them. We got the Chskies, we
got the Finkelestele, we got the
Goldstones, we got them. You ever see
the Muslims come out? The worst Schumer
the worst. Dump Chuck now. That's our
chant. Dump Chuck. I don't care if
Mickey Mouse is running. I'm gonna get
out there and stump for him. Um,
settlers. Well, there are no settlers.
That's another thing. Language.
That's the Bible word though. It's not.
It's Jews in the Jewish homeland. That's
right.
That's what it is. And I'll tell you
something else. There is no occupied
territory. It's Muslim occupied Israel.
Enough. They never tell you that. Look,
there were Palestinian Muslims and there
were Palestinian Jews. Understand that.
Okay. Also understand that the Muy of
Jerusalem had waged campaigns on the
Jews in Hebrron in
1921 in
1929. The Muy of Jerusalem again he has
a huge
whitewash was a partner of Hitler. He
lived in Berlin from 1941 to 1945. He
delivered the Muslim world to Hitler. He
raised Muslim armies in Bosnia.
um as Slovenia. He was responsible for
the death of 400,000 Jews, mostly women
and children from Hungary, uh Slovenia,
um Austria, and nobody talks about
Islam's role in World War II. Why? But
really, why? Everybody paid. As a matter
of fact, according to uh it was um um oh
uh which was it Ikeman Ikeman's deputy
in the Nermberg trials, it was the Muy
of Jerusalem, Al Husini, who was pushing
for the death camps. He had plans for a
death camp right outside of
Nablas. And at the Wii conference when
the final solution was was being
announced and they had all the economic
ministers and the political ministers
and all the advisers at Wansi in
Germany, the economic minister said,
"Why are we doing this? We have free
labor. The Jews are great. It's free. We
work them like dogs. It's a it's just
it's a cash cow. Why would we do
this?" And Hitler said that he was
inspired by the Armenian genocide.
Another thing you're not allowed to talk
about, another jihad against Christians
to the tune of 1.5 million, right? And
now there was a resolution passed that
to say that it was a genocide. Oh, that
upset the Muslim world. You're not
allowed to say that. And now Turkeykey's
pissed off at us. And Obama's Obama
campaigned on the promise that he would
call Armenia genocide. He campaigned on
it. Not so fast now, he said. Not so
fast because you know my campaign
promises. You
know, you know what they're worth. So,
what I'm saying is is that there's a
huge history here. There's a 14-year
history of jihadi wars, enslavements, um
how they treat their women. I am
fighting just I am fighting for the
basic human right of freedom of speech,
freedom of religion, freedom of
conscience. And don't tread on me.
Period.
[Applause]
Um, I would be more than happy to answer
questions. I don't know how much time I
have. I've just been like ranting on
here. I don't know if I've gone over or
whatever. Hey, Pam. Yes. Question real
quick. Do you uh associate pretty much
with Act for America at all? They're a
great group. Yes, I do. I mean, we we we
sort of uh Oh, we we do things in
tandem. I mean, I'm doing this rally.
Stop the Islamization of America's doing
a rally. Bread is sending out a
petition. Listen, the problem with the
petition is Bloomberg is behind it. You
know, Bloomberg, Mayor Bloomberg has
sitting on his human rights committee.
Get this, human rights
committee, Omar Muhammadi. Omar
Muhammadi is the council for the Council
of American Islamic Relations. They're
the council. Wait a minute, it gets
worse. For care. He's suing the airlines
for the six imams. He was suing the Jane
and the John Doe's until Congress passed
legislation to protect them. So
understand this. The mayor of the city,
if you see something, say something, has
sitting on his human rights commission,
the lawyer who's suing the people that
saw something and said
something. It's going to have to be the
people. Do I think that they will not do
it uh because of public outrage to be
sensitive? I don't. But I tell you, we
gota if we don't have a big show June 6,
it's over. You got to stand for
something or you'll fall for anything.
Yeah. May I make a comment? Yes.
In keeping with what this young lady
said about the Jews, if you want to know
what's happening in
Jerusalem, find out how you can get the
Jerusalem Post. I have had it for five
years and you get an allgether different
slant on what is happening in that
area. They also have a publication
called the Jerusalem report. Okay. Yes.
And I want to just say one thing. Israel
National News is better. Well, either
one. Yeah. Yes, it's true. But you'll
get a different slant on what you're
reading in the present newspap. Okay. I
am told that my time is up. I did put on
on CPAC, the Conservative Political
Action Committee in Washington, because
there was nothing on Islam, nothing on
Islamic Supremacism, nothing on jihad. I
out of my own pocket, Robert Spencer and
I, we did a um a uh conference with some
of the lead world's leading experts on
Islam. Even Steve Coglin, who was fired
by the Pentagon, he's a specialist on
Islamic doctrine, the threat doctrine,
was fired by Hessam Islam. You shocked.
He's speaking here. If you want you I
I'll put them outside. You can buy them.
It's It's two hours. It's enormously
instructive and interesting. It's called
Jihad, the political third rail. What
they're not telling you. Okay. Thank you
everybody. Thank you for coming.
How are you?